believe me members before we start the
meeting I'll just read out the emergency
evacuation announcement so we'd be
required to evacuate the building will
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit to the Chamber's
on our assembly point we'll be in the
public car park at the side of the Civic
Suites please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting meeting will be audio recorded
can i please remind you to switch off
your mobile phones or turn them on side
right now please be upstanding to
receive the chairman unfortunately our
Reverend Reverend Isles is unwell
tonight so he's unable to be here he
sends his best wishes and his blessing
and hope you join with me to send him
our best wishes turn
stop meeting everyone I think to the
minutes of meeting held on the 20th of
February 2018 are there great members
are to strain to receive declarations of
interest
I spoke up don't approach to look in the
interests of 13th being a member of the
subcommittee yeah in regards to that
like exempt item and also remember item
for announcements for the chairman
leader or head of paid service I think
this I'm just like to say we've got a
number of new members of staff to write
for Council here tonight come to see how
things work so let's do things correctly
tonight so I just like to say welcome to
you and you're observing the meeting
tonight that pure beef welcome you can
enjoy funny interesting Thank You
chairman let's portfolio holder for HR I
would like to
they've given up their region here
tonight they take a great interest in
our council and we are I won't go
through all the things that I've been
doing over the last little while because
it just things up as a long list and I
think it perhaps gets a little bit
tedious for those listening but just to
tell you that I've been to many things
I've been schools I've seen young people
I've been to other areas in in Essex and
I've made some really good contacts and
it's been very interesting and to
represent all of you on and the
residents of thank you item five the
public questions and members questions
on notice there are none item six
business for my last council meeting
[Applause]
item 72 note the minutes of executive
and committee meetings held between the
periods the 10th of February 2018 and
the 13th of April 2018 which will have
that note it is each occasion at night
to consider any reports of the executive
and committees to counsel and first time
we've got is an ax report of the report
hours of the showw power help advise the
coils which was not even appreciated
because the report it was were happy
attached report in the appendix this is
a statutory the end of the content of
the report is paying self-explanatory
so the recommendation is it is proposed
that count for yourself to seek the
enemy item 9 report on alleged decisions
there are none
item 10 report of the leader on the work
effective and even have a chair members
this is my fifth ordinary Council
meeting of the 2017-18 minutes every
year much more more members since the
meeting on the 20th of February
there have been no meetings of the
executive which is our that said before
but clearly it's no point in having a
meeting equal nothing to discuss other
matters that my colleagues and I on the
executive that we include the releasing
the drops housing allocation policy 2018
that intercedes for for terms of
consultation agreeing the
recommendations to allocate grant
funding to local voluntary and community
organizations responded to print with
Borough Council's preferred site
allocations consultation 2018 and
transferred city councilors
pre-submission local plan consultation
bringing the revised and combined
policies relating to private sector
housing services in tackle world homes
financial assessment policy and 2018-19
schedule of fees relating to private
sector housing services agreeing the
timetable of meetings for the 2018-19
municipal year
agreeing to remove committee development
rights on there to the west of 211 to
241 rectory Avenue Ashenden and 9 to 23
Ashington white smashing them agreeing
the scope and the considerations of
strategic outgoing case as I see as it
relates to Rochford District and
delegating approval of the final SOC to
the assistant director community and
Housing Services now finally adopting
the street street scene enforcement
policy as always I'll be happy to take
any questions from members through you
Journal in respect of the work that the
accept it and I'm sure my executive
privilege will be happy to contribute
1812 is exclusive the pressing public
and to agree that the president publicly
excluded from the meeting for the
remaining business on the grounds except
information as defined in paragraphs
three of part one of set of twelve a at
the Local Government Act 1972 would be
disclosed is that agree